now this
process of babbling it seems to me as
far as i understand it's like poking a
prodding to test your own self model to
see what's the difference between me and
the world it sounds like that
never stops even though we
call it babbling as if infants do it
does it ever stop are we not engaging in
this right now
and i like this phrase babbling all the
way down
i'm gonna put that on a t-shirt by the
way chris or and it also by the way
seems like babbling all the way up too
because we're constantly engaging in
this
so firstly is that true
does babbling have an end
and
and also does it not
presume a self
in order to test the self
what i mean is carl when you were
speaking about
the process of babbling it's the infant
doing something on the world in order to
make a model
but that first part was it it is doing
something to the world to me already
presumes the external world whereas the
way that i'm understanding it is that
the self is a model but it's also
in your point of view it's something
objective and i believe from my readings
of chris
i don't i believe chris is more on the
non-dual end where it's it's it's
that's less the case so i'm unsure
anyway i just said a slew so please
respond to it as you
as you wish
right well i mean just to um
dispel the notion that the self is um
objective no i i didn't mean that i i
meant it exactly the same way that um i
think both chris and mike have been
intimating that you know from the inside
of a cell or a person or the baby's
skull um
self um is you know
quite a a sophisticated um construct um
you know fantasy hypothesis um that is
physically realized possibly neurally in
some lucky creatures and some lucky
children uh you may actually find some
children never get that far you know i'm
thinking here people with severe autism
for example who don't have a theory of
mind simply because they never developed
the notion that um
i am a
person um and you know what comes along
with that is that
you know if you've got very very severe
autism or you know if you like sort of a
theoretically idealized autism and that
means that personhood it doesn't exist
so you would be i would regard you as an
animate french or you know
some um
interesting autonomous vehicle but you
would never be a person because i don't
i don't have the hypothesis that you
know there are people out there and that
people share certain sort of phenotypic
characteristics and um have intentions
in the same sense that i have intentions
so i just i'm not aware of that because
i just don't don't have that hypothesis
so it's a long-winded way of saying that
i didn't mean to imply
any objectivity here i was more going
the other way really i'm just saying
that selfhood um
that would be one part of consciousness
and if you
want to associate cognition and
consciousness then possibly um that kind
of minimal selfhood would you know would
be necessarily part of um
of cognition
this is a gift
that you have to get by crossing one of
those bright lines
um and it's just a fantasy that you
bring to the table to make sense of uh
all the impressions on your sort of
sensory surface or your holographic
screen or your or your cell surface or
also the receptors you are equipped with
to sense what's going on out there